welcome to this video dr. wily from
Finland let's see I Queens gambit
accepted yeah I really want this porn
back a 6 here yeah probably probably not
really a way to punish that yeah i think
i think i had this on the board once you
know in a tournament game maybe even a
five now and try to isolate this beep on
95 and stuff and 95 maybe 95 I know G to
Hanks but this Queen a for business this
is dangerous Queen 84
let's see yeah I can go to d6 now which
this or this whole thing has taken up
some time but it's nice to have this
blockade okay so II five yeah II five
looks like something that might help him
should I play a form to stop this I mean
Quincy eight not sure about that what is
the idea 95 e7 or okay I can also just
put the night on see form taking on d6
you cannot play Knight be eight or
something in any way as the rook hangs
on ad yeah and now it will be very
difficult for him to free himself yeah
II five is prevented there is very
little act of play Bishop d to Roxy one
Bishop f3 I have natural simple ways to
improve the pollution yeah I will do
this Queen a8 can be prevented maybe
maybe the night now hmm and then it can
play see five it's not like great but he
can what's their way to prevent that not
sure now probably there was
with bit more precision
hmm
okay I'm Bishop t2 and Roxy one
ok
yeah okay ma'am the main danger he is
that I'm falling asleep and we'll get
into time pressure so let's let's try to
speed up going for one good ending it's
obviously a little bit of a shame that i
didn't get more out of it but okay then
let's just play this ending okay look
before Luke c6 lights both good so let's
not lose too much sleep about it
yeah okay probably look D for this
Bishop e3 winning the exchange so just
put the TM jump let's show at least I'm
threatening now to take and rook c8
again oopsie six
trying to get to lasik spawn now you can
maybe just take it i also have this
should be two witnesses sam this is an
important thing
and I really would like to okay my back
rank it's not that weak but it's always
a slight issue when you okay okay i can
take a six
sted drawback like night c7 the dropsy
six is good yeah okay this one ok let's
protect it it's opposite colored bishops
if he takes but at least my bishop is on
a eight for them for the pawn preparing
the pawn push so we're just taking now
yeah make it trying to try to play play
simpler now ok we are not that that far
behind on the clock that's good a g4
would have been useful I'm doing that
fixing this weakness on age six and my
King has ideas to end them d3si 2 and so
on yeah that looks good it's a very good
controller now yeah let's take it very
little reason not to take it
time Jane can also take here maybe just
take him
now if it is not taking a play age 7 and
the rook endgame oops age 74 i guess but
i can go here first and then play h7 to
promote
check
yeah okay Tilda until the bitter end
check check check mate yeah it was a bit
a bit strange that that he got out of it
somehow he tells me lega yeah like I
lost I won the game because of some some
issue with my connection rather ask
yourself while you were basically
positionally dead after 10 moves yeah um
the question is can I somehow improve
this so that he does not even get the
sepan moving huh maybe he can manage it
this rook a7 thing let's let's look I
mean I'm pretty sure that up to here
this is like almost almost certainly the
best here and what now does this looks
good he went here I went they went here
maybe this isn't the most precise given
the fact that he will play Knight B aid
and c5 I probably should prefer bishop
ever d to maybe this and if we now have
this idea i also have Queen f3 now okay
and if we go here this may be a bit
better now in comparison because it's
not that clear that matt bishop man that
was wrong not that clear that my bishop
belongs on f3 but it also always a text
here so maybe this is really better this
this kind of situation if he now takes i
take the end
just win this yeah that's it's much
better ya black ass is in a very bad
situation you will lose a pawn probably
one of those and it's still two bishops
and so on so this is probably better
keeping keeping the advantage a bit
bigger than what happened here white is
also better it's not not a big issue but
I was really hoping to get more out of
it and around here it feels like and the
worst is over for him yeah okay hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching